here in the US the Paris attackers
touched off a ferocious debate about
Syrian refugees
you might remember President Obama had
pledged to accept at least 10,000 over
the next year but after news broke that
one of the attackers may have posed as a
refugee and entered Europe through
Greece with a fake Syrian passport many
US officials have second thoughts
31 governors now oppose are refusing or
suspending the resettlement of Syrian
refugees into their states okay that's
pretty extreme but it's also pretty
meaningless for two reasons one
governors don't have the legal authority
to ban refugees and two even if they
could Syrians can just walk between
states like anyone else the lines on
maps are not crocodile filled most
presidential candidates also got
involved with this anti-refugee rhetoric
Donald Trump ben Carson and Marco Rubio
called for a halt to all Syrian refugees
entering the country and others like Ted
Cruz and Jeb Bush argued we could take
some if they were Christian and if
you're wondering how that would work
let Jeb Bush explain what is the focus
on Christian families actually look like
is that gonna what you're Christian I
mean you can prove you're a Christian
it's difficult
I think you can prove it I think you can
prove it
I'm pretty sure you can prove it you see
I'll tell ya you see a Christian has
ears that protrude out from their head
whereas non-christians lack external
ears altogether you know what hold on
I'm thinking about seals and sea lions
often get them confused forget
everything I said about Christians and
Muslims I don't know what I'm talking
about and it was not just Republicans
the Democratic mayor of Roanoke Virginia
David Bowers was so terrified of Syrian
refugees
he used the worst possible historical
example to prove his point mayor David
Bowers wrote I'm reminded that President
Franklin D Roosevelt felt compelled to
sequester Japanese foreign nationals
after the bombing of Pearl Harbor
it appears the threat of harm to America
from Isis now is just as real and
serious as that from our enemies then
Wow did he not realize that Japanese
internment camps are one of this
nation's greatest sources of shame it's
one of the parts of FDR's legacy his
family would most like you to forget and
bear in mind this is a man whose own
biopic featured a scene of him getting a
from his distant cousin
[Music]
did I have to show you that no did I
want to absolutely I did but this week's
this week's events actually call to mind
a chapter from FDR's time in office that
is even more shameful than the saddest
and classiest hand job of all time
specifically when in 1939 US authorities
turned away a ship containing more than
900 mostly Jewish refugees from Germany
something American newsreels at the time
tried to put a positive spin on 907
Jewish unfortunates without a country
permitted to land in Belgium after five
weeks of suspense afloat through
American generosity they will find at
least temporary shelter in France
Holland and England yes
we sent a boat of Jews back to Europe in
1939 more than a quarter of them then
died in the war so this Thanksgiving
when your grandmother's complaining
about your new piercing saying your
generation is terrible simply reply okay
Nana but at least we didn't send Jews
back to Europe in 1939 then break off a
turkey legs drop it like a microphone
and you've just won the dinner dinner
over let's be honest here and every
generation has had its own ugly reaction
to refugees whether they are the Irish
the Vietnamese the Cubans or the
Haitians and those fears have been
broadly unfounded in fact there was only
one time in American history when the
fear of refugees wiping everyone out did
actually come true and we'll all be
sitting around a table celebrating it on
Thursday and look it is absolutely fair
it's fair to be concerned about safety
in the wake of these attacks and it's
fair to wonder who we're letting in and
what sort of screening system is in
place unfortunately many of the people
talking about it this week don't seem to
have the first idea of what we're doing
do we know who these people are no are
they properly vetted no how do you vet
them there's no possible way to vet them
there's virtually no vetti
because there are no databases in Syria
there are no government
records we don't know who these people
are look it is difficult to vet people
coming out of a warzone but it's not
like we're just letting anyone in we are
the United States of America not Arizona
State because just for the record
here let me walk you through what our
screening process actually is if you're
a refugee first you apply through the
United Nations High Commissioner for
Refugees which collects documents and
performs interviews incidentally less
than 1% of refugees worldwide end up
being recommended for resettlement but
if you're one of them you might then be
referred to the State Department to
begin the vetting process at this point
more information is collected are you we
put through security screenings by the
National Counterterrorism Center the FBI
and the Department of Homeland Security
and if you're a Syrian refugee you'll
get an additional layer of screening
called the Syria enhanced review which
may include a further check by a special
part of Homeland Security the USCIS
fraud detection and national security
Directorate and don't relax yet because
we've barely even started then you
finally get an interview with USCIS
officers and you'll also be
fingerprinted so your prints can be run
through the biometric databases of the
FBI the Department of Homeland Security
and the Department of Defense and if you
make it through all that you'll then
have health screenings which let's face
it may not go too well for you because
you may have given yourself a stroke
getting through this process so far but
if everything comes back clear you'll be
enrolled in cultural orientation classes
all while your information continues to
be checked for currently against
terrorist databases to make sure that no
new information comes in that wasn't
caught before all of that has to happen
before you get near a plane this process
typically takes 18 to 24 months once
you've been referred by the UN to the
United States this is the most rigorous
vetting anyone has to face before
entering this country not know
terrorists in their right mind would
choose this path when the visa process
requires far less efforts but but
nevertheless the House still voted on
Thursday to add a few more steps the
House voted 289 to 137 for tougher
screening procedures requiring the FBI
director to sign off on each and every
refugee he signs off oh that is
ridiculous at this point why don't we
just include a pie-eating contest
be and an evening where portion but the
really hard truth here is no one can
promise that someone dangerous still
might not slip through and what that
risk should not be denied it also should
not be wildly inflated let me ask this
if you bought a five-pound bag of
peanuts and you knew that in the
five-pound bag of right notes there were
about ten peanuts that were deadly
poisonous would you feed them to your
kids the answer is no yep of course it's
no for a start you should give your kids
an actual meal not a handful of peanuts
because they're human children not
circus elephants but but second we
wanted to do the math on what he just
said so we bought five pounds of peanuts
and we counted them there are about a
thousand nuts in there so if ten of them
are poisoned mike huckabee is
essentially suggesting that about one of
every 100 refugees is a terrorist but in
reality of the more than seven hundred
eighty four thousand refugees admitted
to the US since 9/11 only three have
been arrested for planning terrorist
activities none of which by the way
resulted in attacks here so the actual
known ratio of arrested terror suspects
to refugees is not one in a hundred it's
one in roughly two hundred and sixty one
thousand peanuts themselves have killed
far more people in the last decade than
terrorist refugees I'll go one step
further men named Mike have killed more
people than terrorist refugees and I
don't see us rounding all of them up and
that's kind of the point
because as reasonable adults we accept
tiny amounts of risk baked into our
everyday lives we drive cars despite
knowing around $30,000 died in them each
year we go swimming despite the fact ten
people a day dying from died from
drowning 20 Americans every year are
killed by cows but no one is saying we
should expel all cows from the country
we're happy just taking them out one at
a time thinking well we got them before
they got us
is what freedom tastes like any rational
person knows you cannot completely
eliminate risk you can only manage it
and we do it with peanuts and cars and
and swimming and hamburgers and men
named bike because we rightly think that
they're worth the risk and I would argue
for the tremendous good we could do and
the low level of risk involved refugees
are worth it too and you may disagree
but it is worth noting that as we devise
new ways to close our doors this week
France which had just suffered a terror
attack and has far less ability to
police its borders did this French
president Francois Hollande says France
will still welcome refugees into the
country despite the Paris massacre
speaking at a gathering of the nation's
mayor's he said France will keep its
commitment to take in 30,000 refugees
over the next two years
a lond added that France will remain a
country of freedom yeah because they
think it's worth the risk
and it's frankly not ideal that Francois
Hollande a man who broke up with his
partner of 30 years in order to shack up
with a lover who looks exactly like her
just 10 years younger only to quickly
leave that lover for another lover who
looks exactly like the second lover just
10 years younger again that man is
currently functioning as an effective
moral compass for our politicians
you